also it's interesting bring up yoga
because yoga was from India which is
where Buddhism came from and then
Buddhism spread to China and they
brought the yoga with them so that's why
the Shaolin Kung Fu has yoga elements
they do a lot of stretching and all that
so a lot of the martials came from yoga
so again it's very American to go like
this is useless why the [__] anyone do
this but they don't see like how Stuff
evolved from other stuff you know it's
just super American to be short-sighted
and to not appreciate anything around it
and to just don't know how to criticize
yeah not think long term yeah you're
right but you are born in America so
yeah your mindset is yeah it's very you
know what can you even speak Korean oh
you can great yeah yeah is that only
phrase you know no I don't otherwise
parasite you turn on the subtitles
I do you do yeah okay well that's you
know because
all right so it's like so um what I want
to say is I could probably watch
um a kids show right in Korean okay and
not turn on the subtitles Primary School
level primary yeah right because I was
born in San Diego yeah right I've made
that very clear exactly yeah and I want
to I want to re-clear it and clarify
sure I was born here okay good okay and
I don't know much I didn't go to college
I didn't go to law school did you even
go to high school
he got an empty diploma
it's amazing how talented you are
despite very little school yeah I went
to my first rehab at 15. really yeah
whoa all right so I had some problems
yeah yeah I had some problems can you
read
where'd you learn how to read I know how
to read well oh well okay see me at
table read yeah why do you do this write
me a [__] movie we'll do a table read
you just do a movie together I think it
would be funny someone mentions like
they said Odd Couple you guys I do think
so
but I could play his dad
no no I can't play your dad what's the
age difference it's a weird one because
he looks young so he's not old enough to
be my dad he looks like he's my
I don't know the brother older brother
maybe the brother yeah you're very well
preserved for your age
that's good yeah is that good yeah
that's a good thing yeah sorry sorry I
know you're very American well preserved
means like you look good for your age
yeah I I've eaten Jam before what what
Jam like jam preserved that's preserved
yeah okay yeah so I know what preserved
means all right you put a fruit in a
thing yes fruit in a thing and then you
eat it put it on [__] friends okay
okay roasted bread all right kimchi is
preserved kimchi is very good very good
five stars right and it's also there's a
lot of probiotics amazing all right
amazing so there's certain things I do
now
how do you spell preserved P okay
he's good eh
s
preserved no no let me try Okay let me
finish okay
e-r-e-s e-r-v-e Preserve
okay that's good good here I have a
question for you is that right yes
correct okay what about why'd you say no
when I say I was trying to psych you out
don't be a spelling bee [__] judge
all right the kids would freak you get
freaked out I have a challenge could
have
ah could have
see
OU
LD
a process Apostrophe a prostitute a
prostitute
very good yeah yeah all right give him
one give him one anybody who grows up in
Asia like our our spelling is impeccable
give a banana
give them banana it'll throw them for a
loop
banana
b-a-n-a-n-a whoa crazy I couldn't do
that but that is hard for me I always
believe it I always put two ends when I
say car what do you hear
cartoon yeah that's no you say cartoon
yeah it's there's no R when you say it
are you one of those agents I can't say
they are I think I can say the r my name
is Ronnie
that's true yeah yeah yeah but what yet
he doesn't call himself Ani but I don't
know what I'm I don't know what you guys
feel when I talk when you say well I I
at most of the worlds I can't understand
you can't understand India I'm saying
this no I understand most of the words
right but when you say R it's a little
weird you say it in a Bostonian way
yes it's not Asian it sounds more
Bostonian uh well I use I spent some
time in New Hampshire does that oh did
you really yeah yeah when I was a kid I
was I grew up in New Hampshire a little
bit oh oh they didn't know that yeah
that's interesting Manchester New
Hampshire oh I didn't know that so maybe
that's where you got what are your
thoughts on someone like um Hilaria
Baldwin like fully adopting a Spanish
accent you care about that no I don't
even know who it is